hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and welcome
to 2020 hope everyone's having a good
new year so far I'd like to start a
tradition of starting off each calendar
year with a bang podcast wise last year
to begin 2019 we had Sir Roger Penrose
one of the world's most famous
scientists in the public sphere but also
someone whose enormous ly respected by
his professional colleagues so this year
in 2020 we're gonna start off with
Daniel Dennett who is a philosopher who
is as well known as any philosopher is
in the modern age among the general
public and also once again
extraordinarily respected among his
professional colleagues I in particular
have enormous respect for what Dan has
done and part of it is just that our
attitudes are very similar our
approaches to what we do are very
similar if you know it would not be
completely wrong to say that when I am
in a more philosophical mode I'm trying
to do for physics what Dan has been
trying to do for biology and
neuroscience and consciousness over the
course of his career as we'll talk about
in the podcast we we go it's a long
podcast it's a long episode we cover an
enormous amount of ground so individual
topics are breezed through very quickly
but there's a theme there's a framework
that ties it all together which is this
idea of taking what science teaches us
about the world and connecting it to the
world of our everyday experience you
know for whatever science teaches us it
is very often going to be the case that
even though it comes ultimately from our
experience of the world the ultimate
theories that we end up building might
seem very different very surprising even
disconcerting the Big Bang cosmology
quantum mechanics Darwinian evolution
are things that you wouldn't have just
guessed just on the basis of your
everyday experience without enormous
amounts of observation and
experimentation into realms that you
don't see in your everyday life and
therefore the theoretical frameworks you
develop don't
or feel much like our everyday world
this is especially noticeable when it
comes to things like consciousness
freewill
the nature of human beings so what Dan
Dennett has devoted his career to are
taking discoveries from science whether
it's neuroscience or biology or
what-have-you
computer science artificial intelligence
and teasing out their philosophical
implications he is one of the world's
leading philosophical naturalist s-- not
a naturalist in the sense of going out
into the forest and poking around the
trees and the animals but a naturalist
in the sense of not being a super
naturalist an ontology that says there
is only the natural world so how do you
then explain things like purposes and
meanings and other things that we human
beings naturally associate with our
lives here in the world that's what Dan
has been trying to figure out for the
course of his whole career and so we
have a wonderful discussion back and
forth where we both ask each other
questions because he's thought very very
deeply about the nature of existence the
world we live in the nature of thought
how we conceptualize what's going on and
questions that are very important to me
like emergence and intentionality how
it's ok to talk about things like
purposes and choices in a world that is
ultimately governed by the laws of
physics
so I already said previously and I think
maybe don't only to patreon subscribers
but this is probably my favorite podcast
interview that I've ever done and I
think that you're gonna enjoy it just as
much remember we have a web page for
Posterous universe comm slash podcast
where you can find show notes
transcripts of every episode an eagle
can also find a link to support
mindscape if you like on patreon and
patreon supporters get benefits like
monthly ask me anything episodes and
episodes that are completely ad free so
this is gonna be very very fun episode I
hope you enjoy it as much as I did let's
go
[Music]
denne denne welcome to the mindscape
podcast so I do with you you had a
little thing that you said when I was in
the room one time that I'm sure you've
said many many times but it really
struck a chord with me talking about
Wilfred sellers and the manifest image
and the scientific image and how you
thought of your task as a philosopher to
reconcile these why don't you tell us
why we begin setting the stage by
telling us what these are oh good I'm
glad you asked Wilfrid Sellars great
American philosopher said the job of
philosophy was to explain how things in
the broadest sense of the term hang
together in the broadest sense of the
term
well that sounds sort of trivial how
things hang together
well but what he had in mind is this
there's all the things of the everyday
world colors and sounds and haircuts and
pains and dollars and homeruns those are
all things and then in the scientific
world there's there's electrons and
quarks and fields and molecules and how
do we relate the things of our everyday
sort of pre scientific world to the
things that science has discovered and
what a hundred years and more have shown
is there's no simple answer what's very
winded sellers say this in 1961 or two
so but I mean when I say a hundred years
I mean let's say since Einstein that's
when the world really starts to look
weird from the scientific point of view
and you have people saying really it's
all just atoms on the void and there's
no such thing as solidity and
there's no such things as colors and
after all atoms aren't colored and the
world of atoms is an empty space and we
can go on from there so at one extreme
you have people who have insisted that
the scientific image that's the gold
standard that's what sets what's real
that's reality that's reality everything
else is illusion but as a cartoon I like
puts it reality maybe the world we live
in may be an illusion but it's the only
place you can get a good cup of coffee
so it's not very helpful to be told that
not only do dollars and homeruns not
exist but colors don't exist and pain
doesn't exist yeah and and you know
solidity doesn't exist so we have to we
have to negotiate between the two worlds
that's seller says that's what
philosophy is for and I think yeah I
agree that's about as good a definition
of philosophy as I can think of but
you're adding a little bit right I mean
one could buy into sellers this
formulation while still denying that the
manifest image is capturing something
real right oh yeah yeah I mean seller's
image leaves all the options open yeah
these leaves open both the hard core
scientific realists who says everything
else is just illusion eliminative ISM is
philosophers say or you go the other
extreme and say the the the electrons
and quarks and all that's just a useful
fiction what's really real estate and
chairs and people and ideas and love and
so forth and so those are the two
extremes and then there's all kinds of
positions in the middle
and my view which might seem to be
giving up especially to philosophers is
to think we have to learn how to get
back and forth between these two images
the manifest image and the scientific
image but the way we do that is not by
strict definitions that are
counterexample proof the way we do it is
with diplomatic and pedagogical ways of
easing the passage and we just this may
be an old example voices our voice is
real okay what's a voice what's it made
of
is it a is it a bodily part is it is it
biological material but you can record a
voice you can recognize a voice
it has causal power in the world it has
right voices if you say what category of
thing they are you you run out of it
seems to be almost in a category by
itself well all right fine we we don't
need a voice throat problem to go with a
mind-body problem we we we may not know
how to answer the question of what
voices are but we're not mystified we're
not puzzled we're not baffled it's just
the curious fact about the way language
and and our perception of the world our
pre-scientific perception of the world
carbs things up and and the
otolaryngologists and the and the other
biologists can and the acoustic
engineers can tell us all about voices
without we don't ever have to settle
that issue right I labeled this view in
my book the big picture poetic
naturalism being the motto being that
there's only one world the natural world
but there are many ways of talking about
it and those ways all can capture some
elements of reality and it's Aleta
them illusions just because they're not
the most fundamental thing I think
that's good yeah I think I think that I
think that's that's about yeah that's
about right now the idea was not
supposed to be anything original it's
just a label you know to help us will
understand because there are there are
people who want to who are alive into
mists right who want to say that some of
these higher-level struggles wouldn't
count as real yeah and and I've been a
battling against that view for decades
so I'm sure we'll get there but just to
you know label just put things on the
table so before we get there so
therefore you will think of things as
such as consciousness and freewill as
real yeah for exactly this kind of
reason yeah real but they're not what
you think they are not what we think
they are right okay I mean that's that's
my motto
X is real but it's not what you think it
is good so you you wrote a paper a while
ago called real pattern yeah and I want
to talk about that a little bit I don't
know if you even are aware that this is
become an important fun topic in quantum
mechanics No yeah David Wallace who is
one of the interests of the Everett or
many-worlds interpretation yeah I'm also
a partisan of leans on your paper and
your notion of real patterns very
heavily in his book the emergent
multiverse okay trying to explain how
the classical world you know forget
about tables and chairs but even you
know electrons with positions and atoms
and things like that are somehow not
there in the most fundamental
formulation of quantum mechanics but
they describe the pattern and therefore
they're real yep wonderful I'm delighted
yeah can you give a sales pitch for what
your view is there and that real
patterns paper what you're trying to get
across the main idea of the paper is
that if we think about information we
think about information theory we
recognize that well to put it in in sort
of
everyday terms how big a file do you
need to capture this particular
phenomenon yeah
and Michiko board which has got just 64
squares and some are black and some are
white pretty easy you can give a very
limited description of that pattern and
and write it on the back of an envelope
if you've got a color picture of
confetti and you have to describe it in
detail you've got a much bigger file
that's why that's why some pictures on
your phone or bigger have used more more
megabytes than other pictures it all
depends on how much complexity there is
in the picture and if there's if there's
no pattern in the picture at all if it's
just random oddly enough that that's one
that takes the most information right to
record because you have to record every
pixel you can't say well there's a
region of deep blue over here and
there's a region of red over here
those are nice concise ways of taking
advantage of the pattern in the
phenomenon so the idea of real patterns
is take any phenomena and are there
patterns in it well what's a pattern a
pattern is a summary of concision
something that permits you to generalize
so that you're better than a coin flip
about what the next little bit of it is
if you've got any predictive edge at all
on the data set that you're looking at
you got a pattern right and it's not
necessarily well I put this way we
should be happily surprised when there
are such patterns in some sense right I
mean if you but what the patterns enable
you to do is to ignore certain pieces of
your having so lately that nature has
designed an evolution natural selection
has designed organisms to be route
this pattern finders to ignore almost
all the information that's officially
available at their surfaces and just
focus in on what matters to them those
are the patterns that if they can latch
on to those they can feed themselves and
avoid getting eaten and live long happy
lives mate and all the rest so the idea
of the pattern is I think a very useful
and deep idea and it can be given a nice
clear mathematical formulation and it's
the key what what science does is fine
spatter but it's also what the manifest
image does right we take for granted all
the patterns that we see if that we do
more than that we over interpret them
mmm that is if we see two things that
look the same shade of green to us we
think well deep deep down there or they
say no they might be green for entirely
different reasons they might be so
called meta Murs and they only look the
same color to us because we're you might
say green green colorblind yeah I'd like
to talk about the great courses plus a
streaming service where you can learn
from courses taught by the great courses
some of the best professors out there
can teach you lectures on everything
from science to business history to
personal development there's something
no matter what you want one course I can
recommend is physics and our universe
how it all works now that sounds like
something I could have taught myself I
did not but it's a wonderful overview of
all of physics all at once so from
subatomic particles quarks and leptons
to stars galaxies in the entire universe
itself the course covers how our
understanding of physics has changed
over time and points towards what we're
going to be learning in the future so
set a goal to learn more this year by
signing up for the great courses plus
today mindscape listeners get an amazing
deal a full month of unlimited access
for free but to get that month you must
sign up using this special URL the
great courses plus.com / mindscape
that's t-h-e great courses plus pl us
calm / mindscape start learning today I
did a podcast with Melanie Mitchell
who's a computer science oh yeah I know
about the struggle of artificial
intelligence to capture common sense
right and in would it be off-base to
think that some of this struggle has to
do with the fact that AI is even very
advanced deep learning networks and so
forth are not as good at finding the
patterns as human intelligence is at the
current state of the art ah good let's
see I think that's true except for the
fact that if you crank your deep
learning system long enough it'll find
patterns where there aren't any patterns
I mean deep learning systems algorithms
are very good at squeezing pattern out
of apparently random data I mean that's
that's how the neuroscientists they
train up a categorize Iran on this fMRI
data about what's going on in people's
heads and they discover they can make a
prediction about what person's going to
do 10 seconds later yeah they can and
that shows that it's a real pattern
right but a lot of the patterns they
find by these methods aren't real that
is they don't react to things
well that's the thing I'm wondering if
because what the AI is what the deep
learning networks are so good at is
manipulating huge amounts of data that
they they don't need to be as tricky as
human beings are going to find the
patterns that let you know prediction
that with fewer that's right so of
course we pay a price for that where
it's not a miracle and the price we pay
for that is that we have a lot of false
positives we see a lot more pattern in
the world and is really there
we we see similarities that are only
similar in that they have the same
effect on us but they're otherwise as
different as can be well what does the
does the word real in the phrase real
patterns have the same meaning as the
word real when we were just talking
about you know baseball's being real
well that was the idea I mean I wanted
to say if we have the concept of a
pattern we do have some pretty good
tests this whether it's real and there's
to put it bluntly can you make money
betting on it hmm if you can it's
predictive it's real and that's a
touchstone of reality that seems to hold
up very well so let's say maybe patterns
are the thing that's most obviously
where we can make a real non real
distinction right and that everything
every other distinction between real and
unreal real and fictional real and bogus
it's somehow dependent on that so if
someone so if there's a room and there's
you know this huge number of atoms in
the room and of course if you were
infinitely smart and I gave you the
location of all the atoms and their
velocities you could predict anything be
laplace's demon but the patterns that
there's the other structures are the
idea that I could give you much less
information than that I could say you
guy there's a baseball and it's headed
toward a window yeah and then you could
infer an enormous amount from that
exactly therefore baseball's are real
enzymes that's right years ago I
concocted an example to show the power
of this where we have a we have a
visiting Martian who's a sort of
laplacian demon and he's in somebody's
house and and the phone rings and the
lady picks up the phone and says
yes dear you you're bringing the boss
home for dinner
do we get a bottle of wine on your way
home see you in half an hour hangs up
okay so now both the woman and the
Martian predict that and within 30
minutes two people are going to walk in
the door one of them holding up a glass
bottle filled with an alcoholic beverage
but the laplacian demon has had to trace
out the whole trajectory stop signs and
the lights and the pain every Photon
every Photon and to the laplacian this
is a miraculous prediction where did she
find how did she do this without all
added information well very simple she
understood what was being said so let's
take this point of view that patterns at
the higher level that captures some some
influence some predictability of the
world and apply it to the difficult
cases right where we have things like
people and agents and another phrase
that you popularized way back in the day
is the intentional stance you know so
one of the sets of controversial
concepts which we might ask are these
real or do they have some special status
are things like intentions reasons why
aboutness right like why these are
meeting around something like that so
how do those boundary contentious words
fit into this picture
oh they fit in beautifully and the
intentional stance patterns are just one
particular set of patterns and they're
the set of patterns that have to do with
living agents and nonliving agents that
living agents have made I don't think
there's any other and what's the
simplest one well when I first started
writing about the intentional stance I
chose a thermostat and said you can
consider the thermostat as a little
agent that can be instructed to keep the
temperature a certain way it senses the
temperature and when the temperature
falls below or below the set it it it
has a desire to to raise the temperature
retreat a thermostat as an agent
surrogate you know you could have a
person standing throwing logs on the
fire but you can replace it with this
dead simple thing and you can explain it
to a child say without going into the
mechanics and their hundred different
ways in other words explain it in terms
of its purpose oh it's rather there is
exactly and if they considered a little
homunculus a little a little agent and
it has one desire only and that is to
maintain the temperature but it has a
way of sensing the temperature and
responding to changes by making an
appropriate move by the way this is the
way that one gets taught about
transistors in physics class as if
there's a little man in there transistor
man who decides how much current electro
well it turns out that this tactic this
strategy of adopting the intentional
stance works throughout biology it works
not just for brains and for higher
organisms it works for bacteria it works
for archaea it works for single-celled
organisms the question is does it work
for things that were smaller and simpler
than that well I like to say we're
robots made of robots made of robots
made of robots made of robots and once
you get down subcellular you get down to
the the kinesins the motor proteins and
tubulin and things like that and or
think of a ribosomes fantastic little
machines you can treat them from the
intentional stance you have a job to do
they have they have a job to do they
know how to do it
one of the things that I particularly
like about motor proteins is that it now
turns out basically they're sailing
they're using the storm of the water
molecules inside the sail and they have
sort of ratchets in their feet so
they're actually selectively using the
energy in the random bombardment of the
water molecules as a source of power and
reminds me of Ricky Skaggs great line I
can't control the wind but I can trim
the sails and that's your basic agent
and it's just a protein right right it's
a little Maxwell demon I mean this is
this is in last just fifteen or twenty
years this has become another hot topic
in physics understanding these
non-equilibrium fluctuations in very
very tiny things and I think that it's
probably still underappreciated in my
personal world how much this
transitioned from the world of
individual particles where it would make
no sense to adopt the president stands
to the to the macroscopic world is
driven by entropy in the arrow of time I
think it's I think I'm not a hundred
percent sure of this but I think the key
element to being an agent is having a
history a history that makes a
difference that is something can happen
to it
that changes it and the changes is it
again it has a sort of memory yeah I
think that's just interesting thing
about electrons they don't pick up scars
or dirt or anything yeah you can't an
electron over over billion years doesn't
change at all and that's a huge
difference
now I had we had a wonderful argument in
San
failure the Santa Fe Institute with
David wolf hurt and his colleagues and
one of our big issues whether tornadoes
countless agents and trying to
particular slider you automatic I can't
do I was against it yeah okay because I
didn't think that the tornado could
actually exploit information as it's a
complex system but surviving agency or
intention to it does not seem to help
so that was but but it was a very
illuminating discussion so either if you
want to look at the boundaries you want
to look at things like tornadoes yeah
yeah or motor proteins right and but in
the biologic in the living world
everything bigger than a motor protein
is is a designed thing and it has
purposes it's got parts that have jobs
to do yeah I think participating in the
arrow of time is probably a necessary
precondition for being a nation in the
sense you know yeah the thing about an
electron is like you said they don't
have scars they don't change over time
really but more complicated things have
different access to the past versus the
future their memories of the past and
they can a little bit all they can do is
predict the future and that's when it
becomes that's when purposes and things
like that become necessary so I what
you're gonna say then is ascribing
intentionality or purposes to things has
a reason why we there's a reason why we
do that a reason we have reasons it
makes sense for ribosomes so it makes
sense in exactly the same way for human
beings they're not in a different way
yeah absolutely and I think it's
interesting to think about the history
of this before there was language you
didn't have any agents that we're
comparing
that were arguing that we're explaining
language brought into the world you know
on to our earth something that Wilfrid
Sellars called the space of reasons and
this is the the space of reasons is
where human persuasion and explanation
and querying and challenging happens the
wise and the because --is and the
arrival the emergence of the space of
reasons that has to have an evolutionary
history too and there's only in one
species so that's why i'm interested so
much in the evolution of language and in
evolution of human minds which are
profoundly different from even
chimpanzee minds or dolphin minds or
whale minds take your favorite birds
take your favorite species human minds
are really different and they're
different precisely because they are
obliged to articulate reasons okay and
they learn how to do this and it's an
imperfect business and some are better
than others but it's the fundamental
basis for morality if you are
responsible it's because you respond to
reason you you can you can't argue a
bear you know human being is supposed to
be persuadable so you can train or teach
a dolphin or a dog or whatever but you
don't give it a reason why it's just
it's pure stimulus and response right
and and
recently in my work I've had lots of
examples of what I call free-floating
rationales this is where we see a
phenomenon the reasons are clear but
they're not the reasons of the organisms
involved so the the spotting are
pranking gazelles of throwing these
great extravagant leaps and they're
running away from the Lions say what are
they doing and it's a tremendous waste
of energy makes it dangerous what
they're doing is they're showing off
they are signaling to the Lions don't
bother trying to catch me I can throw
these big expensive dangerous leaves and
still outrun you go after my cousin over
there you can't do that and the lines
believe them and the evidence for this
is pretty clear I was gonna ask you know
that this is a testable and tested
hypothesis yes and and sure enough the
Lions discriminate and they don't go for
the ones that are stunting now I've
given you the rational explanation the
lions are in effect wise to take this
information that's being offered to them
it benefits both the the speedy gazelle
and the line doesn't have to work it's
hard to get a supper and there's lots
and lots of cases of this but don't
think that the lion understands this or
that the gazelle understands us this is
a rationale that has been uncovered by
natural selection the gazelle just don't
know why it wants to make those leaps it
does if you can the lion doesn't know
why it doesn't care for those jumpy ones
they don't have to know so they are the
beneficiaries of a rational system but
they don't have to understand it and
that's it more or less exactly the same
sense in which alphago doesn't know why
puts a certain token on the board and so
that's right knows what to do
it couldn't tell you what and and
Sutter's soda the ribosomes and every
one of your cells there's a rationale
for every part of the job I mean if you
look at the machinery elegant elegant
engineering but the ribosome doesn't
know
and in fact no agent figured that out in
advance
the winning molecular biologists the
chemists they worked it out for the
first time what the rationale is but the
rationale is secures anything and in
some sense because you know we're all
among philosophers here the fact that we
human beings can attach reasons to this
in this sense has to do with some sort
of counterfactual thought experiment if
the gazelles were not leaping in that
way then we know that the Lions would
chase them even the gazelles don't know
that right no it's the intentional
stance but it's it's like an instinct I
think I think we're we're and I think
probably though it's it's a Alden effect
I think that first first that came on
the scene that is in its articulate form
with human beings discovering they could
they could talk about the reasons why
things were happening but we're very
very good at it and in fact if you want
to see it as an instinct you can go back
and see the early animations of simple
triangles and and circles moving around
on the screen but everybody looks and
says oh the big circles trying to catch
the little circle everybody instantly
sees intentionality and purpose in these
cases infants quite young infants
are puzzled by violations of the
apparent agency in very very simple
displays but in circles and triangles
isn't that kind of an edge case here
because we're saying that the the
ascribing of intentions to human beings
or to the behavior of the gazelles is
real and true
whereas musically is not real and true
in the case of well hang on let's see
whose experiments am I thinking of I
can't think of his name right now German
psychologist when he when he made the
film's to show to people as a sigh he
deliberately set out to create these
intentional patterns I see oh come he so
there was an intention so there wasn't
he wanted to create he wanted to show
that just by and in fact he tested this
by having sort of randomly moving
circles and triangles and people did not
attribute intentionality to those that
was just noise so so so there was and in
the same way
natural selection has enforced the
patterns that we see in the jumping
gazelles and the Lions it's not just for
anthem right so we we can see in tension
where there's none where we're very good
at that it's called paranoid yeah Thomas
Pynchon has some novels about this yes
yes yes I mean so you can see it
emerging I guess you don't use the word
emergence that much but are you happy
with the word emergence is a is a word
that I don't use much because it has a
sordid history and philosophy where
emergence comes to mean
yeah next ball and so this is just use
it all the time but I'm worried if I
might philosophy colleagues if if you
know in fact I when John Holland's wrote
his book emergence I said John you've
gotta put a forward in where you say
what you don't mean and I mean that
I completely approve of John Holland's
work on emergence right because it does
not mean that this is a an inexplicable
pattern precisely not fact I like to
illustrate emergence with John Horton
Conway's life world and the amazing
patterns that emerge there and say look
that's the emergence and that's
completely explainable and predictable
there's there's there's no question mark
anywhere in that system but it creates
stunning emergent effects yeah and you
could you can talk this higher-level
vocabulary Absalom that [ __ ] yeah that's
it that's what emergence gets you I want
to pause for a moment to talk about
policy genius a wonderful tool that
helps you decide what kind of insurance
to get whether it's life insurance home
insurance auto sheron's etc you know he
just started 2020 we're gonna look
forward to a whole bunch of jokes
forthcoming about 20/20 hindsight
because of course it's easier to explain
what did happen than to correctly
predict what's going to happen that's
what good insurance is all about it's
helping ameliorate the fact that you
can't predict exactly what's going to
happen what you can try to do is buy the
right kind of insurance and so policy
genius makes this a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from a large
number of top insurance companies to
find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies and then once you
apply policy genius will handle all the
paperwork and red tape they take the unk
stout of finding the right insurance
policy so even though predicting the
future is very hard don't get
discouraged get life insurance it takes
just a few minutes to find your best
price by applying it policy genius.com
policy genius it's better to get the
future right with that definition of
emergence on the table I mean it seems
to make sense that patterns are real
we're gonna you know ascribe reality to
these higher level things that give us
some way of capturing what's going on
purposes and intentions are in that
bucket like they serve a purpose like so
that is really why that helps us
understand what's going on absolutely so
now we get to consciousness right yes
maybe they'll just let you fit it in and
and it emerges in this innocent sense
and the idea that it's one thing that
everything in the universe is either
conscious or not that it's the light is
on or the light is off that is I think a
fundamental error but it's very
widespread it's just amazing how many
really deep and clever thinkers can't
get it out of their heads that
consciousness is all or nothing
and I think no no it's emergent and in
fact what that means is that the search
for the simplest form of consciousness
Menai hunt it's a wild goose chase
because it emerges and and yes starfish
are have some of the aspects of
consciousness so do trees and bacteria
and as you but not electrons but no not
electrons and we can argue about
motorboat yeah yes but but but once you
write that it's nothing mystical it's
something and the question where do you
draw the line is a is an ill motivated
question that's like where do you draw
the line between night and day do you
have a simple definition of what
consciousness is that you prefer no it's
um you didn't write a book called
consciousness explains I I did and I but
I think that that's in one regard that's
that's the way science proceeds to the
scientists done and sit around wasting
hours and hours and hours trying to
define time yeah energy they they get on
with the theory and once they've got a
really good theory it'll be obvious when
time or energy is and I think that's the
same with consciousness okay I'm still
you both have something in mind yeah
yeah I think that let's talk about human
consciousness or human consciousness is
much more in my view and it's it's an
embattled one but I'm pretty sure of it
the human consciousness is much
different from the consciousness of any
other species and the reason it's hard
to see this is what was many reasons one
is that consciousness has a moral
dimension and we want to be kind to
animals and and and the very idea so we
say well yes dogs are conscious but not
the way we are and people immediately
there they get their backs up and
therefore he's about ready to talk about
mistreating animals and it not matter no
no no
because I think the properties of human
consciousness that we share with dogs
and mammals and birds to some degree
with reptiles and fish
those have moral significance so let's
see if we can take moral significance as
itself a graded notion mmm it's not it's
interesting British law octopus vulgaris
protected it's an honorary vertebrae you
can't it's against the law you know to
throw a live octopus on a hot grill when
did this become against law in the UK
their own sometime in the last 20 years
but it's just it's just it's that one
it's not all cephalopods it probably
should be squid you wanna you know you
wanna throw a squid on a live girl you
can but it's you that you are allowed to
boil a lobster but you are allowed you
know can't do it the British law says
vertebrates yeah cause it is it cut off
right okay and so I think you guys are
okay in general for these tricky
questions right I mean people say well
if you draw the line here then they
argue about either side but the law has
to draw yeah exactly and what we should
recognize is the law draws lines that
are reasonable to the vast majority of
people and we can we can talk about
exception so this is an interesting case
the the wonderfulness of octopus the the
amount of convergent evolution between
octopus and say human beings has enough
over the lunch and I think you know I I
approve I I say yes indeed so but if we
put the moral issue behind us well know
before we put the moral issue behind us
we should know that almost nobody wants
to hold any non-human species
responsible morally responsible for
their behavior that's key they may be as
once as moral patients but they're not
moral agents a bear that kills a tourist
is not committed murder just not yep
because they don't have the mental
wherewithal they don't have the kind of
free will that we have we couldn't have
offered them a reason not to do that's
right we we can't expect them to
appreciate the societal norms that we've
set up and so forth so even so don't
look in the Bears brain and a human
brain for the fact that one of them is
in deterministic determinism has nothing
to do with the issue it has to do with
in for me it has to do with self control
and with degrees of freedom and and
degrees of freedom is a term that I've
been using more and more recently and
really have seeing it come more out of
engineering than out of physics and
thinking a degree of freedom is an
opportunity for control and you can
clamp a degree of freedom and then you
don't have to control it you can just
lock it down in one way or another yeah
how many degrees of freedom do we have
millions billions of because we can
think about so many things we have
orders of magnitude more degrees of
freedom than a bear does that means the
problem with
plead the same number of cells and some
place it easier time yeah it means that
the options that the bear has are a
vanishing subset of the options that we
have and learning to control our perusal
of those options that's not a science
that's an art and it's what we try to
train our kids to grow up so that when
we launch them and they are no longer in
our control that they will be able to
control themselves in ways that will
lead them to have happy and productive
lives and if they can't they're gonna
get in trouble
and we have to have that set of troubles
looming out there for those who can't
control themselves
well you've used the word agent a few
times and I use it all the time but we
haven't described what that word means I
mean it's really a relationship between
agency responsibility consciousness no
is there a simple definition of agent
it's not a conscious well again the
thing is that agents come in all sizes
and shapes too and a few minutes ago we
were talking about bacteria is agents
viruses as agents Evans so that's not
the sense of agent we want something we
want a moral age we want to talk about a
moral agent is not just a a locus of
self-control with a with purposes and an
ability to fend for itself and prolong
its existence and improve its enhance
its circumstances that that's a pretty
good definition of an agent something
that can fend off the second law of
thermodynamics fend off dissolution that
would other you know mountains aren't
agents is erosion just yeah
they can't protect themselves or move or
anything but you can see why tornadoes
are an interesting edge case exactly
that's why that's why tornadoes are an
edge case but at the most sophisticated
as we climb that ladder and I think I'm
a pretty good scale would be um how many
how many degrees of freedom are
available for control and when it gets
up into the billions as it does for even
young children now we're talking about
potential moral agents and a moral agent
is simply a human being at the per
moment we don't have any other we could
but we don't a human being that is
mature enough and as I do with how old
they are
except coincidentally mature enough to
control the degrees of freedom that
matter when they matter and to be able
to foresee and understand the outcomes
of possible actions and act accordingly
so that gives us a pretty good I call it
a member of the moral agents good I
think that that does make sense to me
but but it deviated us from our task
which was you were explaining the
salient features of human consciousness
that's right yeah so one of the curious
features of the way the science is
proceeded here is that many theories of
consciousness only attempt half of
theory
we and this is the inbound path or the
upward path and we get we get from the
photon striking the retina and the sound
waves and up and up through the nervous
system up through the various cortical
areas and then Toa consciousness happens
that's the end of the theory wait a
minute I want to ask my what I call the
hard question and then what happens
what makes whatever you say amounts to
consciousness
what makes that consciousness what does
it enable what does becoming conscious
of this or that enable the agent whose
consciousness is to do or disable that
agent from doing what effects does it
have on those multiple degrees of
freedom and the answer is almost
anything can happen
but we need to have the neuroscientific
theory of how laughs can be true and how
the various sequelae the various
outcomes can spell themselves out I mean
it's some people's theories of
consciousness are a little bit like
somebody who mounts a a closed-circuit
TV camera on a hood of his car and and
puts a receiver under the hood so the
end car can see where it's going
Fenny know yeah what what's going to
consume that information it's Ruth
Milliken talks about the consumers of
representations and in theories
scientific theories of consciousness
there has been a systematic neglect of
the consumers hmm
sorry the consumers are the consumers
are ultimately neural structures that
respond to representations spread all
over the brain in ways that give rise to
the ability of people to report and
reflect on and remember there's a
tremendous difference between sensing
something and noticing that you're
sensing something and noticing that
you're noticing that you're sensing some
the first time I ever was familiar with
your work was the collection you had
with Douglas Hofstadter the mind's eye
and I'm not sure that at that young age
when I came across it I absorbed very
much but the one idea that kept coming
through was this recursive
self-awareness I'm sure looking at
ourselves and that has something to do
with what it means that the recursion
recursion and and Doug is the maestro
there his book I am a strange loop is a
is a really a retelling of what he did
in his earlier work in kurtal a shoe box
and amazing thing about Gerda Shabak is
that it was a best-seller school it
surprised me and a lot of people read it
but a lot of people didn't understand it
now and so he I read the dialogues when
I was a kid yeah so I am a strange loop
is in a way
Doug's attempt to do what Hume did humor
the treatise on human nature which he
said fell dead born from the press and
then he had to write the inquiry so that
people would understand what he was
saying Doug had to write I'm the strange
loop so absolutely right recursion it's
this capacity for indefinite reflection
and reflection on reflection because
whenever you can reflect in this
in effect you create a new object to
think about we well let's take a let's
take a frog the frog has a fairly
complicated life and it's faced at every
moment with a number of opportunities
and it survives if it makes good
decisions at those opportunities those
are degrees of freedom and it controls
them as best you can
frogs are agents they fend for
themselves yeah but they don't know they
have opportunities there's no there's no
sign that they can think about their
opportunities as opportunities reason
this I think quite obvious fact is
hidden from us is what I sometimes call
the Beatrix Potter syndrome whenever we
see a clever animal or animal doing
something that is appropriate and
reasonable sly we are find it almost
irresistible to attribute to the animal
the understanding that we have of what
it's doing and the fact is that very
often it's it's clueless it's the
beneficiary of a very good system it
doesn't have to understand you and it's
and that's even true of a lot of human
behavior one of my favorite examples is
crisis theory of meaning now according
to Paul Grice the late great Paul Grice
when you and I converse when an utter
err I may give you a speech act
my utter of speech and I intend you to
form a belief based on my speech at but
I also intend you to recognize it's that
I have that intention so we get third
order
I intend you to believe right that is
intentionality on both sides we've got
you you've got you've got reflexivity
and crisis theory there was something
clearly wonderful about this theory but
as a theory of human everyday psychology
is it's not kids time deepen wonderful
conversations with their parents and
their peers before they have the
capacity to reflect in this way what you
have to understand is that Christ wasn't
wine he was uncovering the free-floating
rationales of human communication he was
doing the same thing that the that the
ethologist are doing when they figure
out what this spotting is all about yeah
they he's finding the rationales this is
why communication has the forms it does
this is why it works and these are the
conditions and various individuals can
be more or less virtuosic in their
sensitivity to this you wouldn't want to
be constantly thinking about recognizing
the intentions those persons because if
you did you couldn't pay attention to
what they were saying this I think you
have the Frog not worrying too much
about its decision making is fascinating
I did a podcast with Malcolm McIver who
is a neuroscientist and mechanical
engineer Northwestern and he is trying
to explore the idea that one of the
major transitions that led to
consciousness was when fish climbed up
on land hmm the idea being that a fish
swimming around at a few meters per
second is underwater and can only see a
few meters in front of it all of its
evolutionary pressures are to make
decisions very rapidly once you climb up
on land and you can see for kilometres
there's a new space of possibilities
that opens up namely imagine different
possible things to do and contemplate
which one would be best and so he says
that climbing up onto land enabled the
evolution of imagination which was usual
step along the road to consciousness oh
that's nice I'm not sure I believe it
but but it's a nice variation on a theme
that I'm very fond of which and that's
Andrew Parker's idea about the Cambrian
explosion and the Parker hypothesizes
that the shallow ocean became
transparent in a way it hadn't been
before and this suddenly permitted
distil perception permitted eyesight and
that the book is called in the blink of
an eye and he argues that the arms race
of predator and prey locomotion
camouflage armor this all was generated
by a growing transparency and it's not
the only theory out there but it's one
that I think there's got to be an
element of truth in it and I've been
arguing that what we're facing right now
is the second great transparency and
that's the electronic transparency and
everybody's not worried and so they
should be about privacy and yeah we can
we can we can now see farther and we can
see into things we could never see into
before but we can also be watched and
our capacities for better for worse and
so we're now all to invert the image
we're all now living in a fishbowl ok
but wait a minute I wanted you you used
a phrase
that was you did not use the phrase the
hard problem but you use the phrase the
hard question good but there was there's
at least a family resemblance between
the distinction you're drawing between
this sort of bottom-up theories of
consciousness and table game yeah and
Chalmers is distinction between the easy
problem in the heart yeah and and I it's
not coincidental so I ask the hard
question before David raised the hard
problem okay which I've been throwing
pails of cold water on for decades now
and I think that the hard problem
Chalmers problem is precisely the fix
you get yourself into if you stop and
don't try to answer the hard question if
you don't ask the hard questions then
what happens then you're left with this
gobsmacking jaw-dropping mind deadening
mystery for the audience does it just
very briefly let's tell them what the
hard question is that you have in the
hard problem developers like synthesize
David introduces the hard problem by
contrasting it with the easy problems
the easy problem says how does your
brain discriminate things how does it
move your your tongue in language how
does how does it do all the cognition
that you engage in how does it recognize
things and have memory and all the rest
those are the easy problem so what's the
hard problem he by the way recognizes
they're not actually easy they're not
they're not yes but but the hard problem
is the problem with why is it like
anything at all to be mean what and and
what's red what's my experience of red
or pain let's and these are so-called
qualia right and philosophy it's a
philosopher's term comes from the Latin
it just means quality property really
but qualia are a term of art in
philosophy
I think it's a bad one it's a if it's an
artifact of bad theorizing which is led
to you know hundreds of careers of
misguided thinking about mind and
consciousness and alas a lot of
scientists have been seduced by it so
that they think that philosophers have
this idea of quality and quality that's
where the that's where they're going
really gets tough it's explaining qualia
those some are claim for properties
that's the hard problem how do we
explain the qualia and Chalmers has been
arguing for this for decades and
recently he's written a paper on the
meta problem and matter problem is why
do we have a harmful and to which part
of my responses what do you mean we dogs
don't have a hard problem that doesn't
mean they're not conscious it means
they're not reflexively ruminative lee
theoretically conscious of air
consciousness that's only for us and
that's the the hard problem arises as an
artifact of the fact that we're
reflective and in our reflections we
focus on what is otherwise a stunning
embarrassment when we look inside to see
what's going on mainly we can't tell now
you well let's think about think about
seeing for a moment yeah I I look out
the window and I see I see a birdhouse
stake between two trees how do I know I
see it well you know if I close my eyes
that's all right so I now know light has
to bounce off and you know the photons
have to come into my eye and blah blah
blah retina ganglion cells lateral
nucleus but that's nothing to which I
have direct access that's something I
had to learn from books
that's third person knowledge of the
process
my first person knowledge is very
limited I tell you there's a birdhouse
out there how do you know I can see it
what do you mean
well my eyes are open and there it is
well how do you know that you're seeing
a burner well does that look like a
birdhouse but how do you know it looks
like a birdhouse what's going on inside
I don't know it just looks like I work I
can describe it in more detail if you
want no nobody is freaked out apparently
by the fact that neuroscientists can
come in and figure out all these amazing
details about what happens between the
eyeball and the lips let's say but
mainly between the eyeball and your
experience well notice that that's only
half the story
the other half of the story is and what
happens between experience and your
ability to talk about it and answer all
these questions well it's just as much
neuroscience that has to go into that is
yeah it has to say one of the first
right now if you stop with experience
then you simply it's like declaring
victory halfway through the mouth now
you've got the whole rest of a theory
you don't have a theory of consciousness
until you've explained what happens next
I like to point out that if you have a
theory of consciousness
that still has a witness in it mm-hmm
you've only got half a theory see you
want to turn experience into something
going on in the brain in their eyes all
the reactions a good theory of
consciousness when we finally have one
it will be like live menses mill will
Walker I would be like a deserted
factory there's nobody home
there's no agents it's all just
machinery that a theory of consciousness
simply has to have that form and people
who resist that like Chalmers they've
got a hard problem in fact they've got a
systematically impossible problem and I
at least I'm saying I'll show you how to
get out of the hard problem namely by
asking and then answering the hard
question and then what happens and my
way of doing that now I've hit on this
with the philosopher Keith Frankish have
you ever piloted a drone a little you
know so you've had the remote unit in
your hands and you're making the drone
go where it's going you're looking at
the little screen and and using the
joysticks and on all right think of that
that remote controller for the drill and
that's the Cartesian theater outside
it's a control room for the job so now
supposedly we're going to emancipate a
drum in other words all the control
decisions that you doing while you're
piloting the drum we're going to upload
those put them on board the drum it's
already got a lot of self control
already on board but we want to we want
to get every last bit of decision-making
and discrimination and noticing and so
forth and control we want to move it all
into the job to do that we will be
asking and answering the hard question
because notice by the way the first
thing you do once you start doing that
and she I throw away the screen who
needs the screen right you don't need
the screen you've already got all the
spatial information in just the form you
wanted for offloading namely you've got
it into into bitstream center that can
be computed you've got you've got just
the medium you need now that may not be
the brains medium but at least you've
got it into the medium that you're gonna
have to get it into for controlling the
drone in various ways and in our thought
experiment very extended thought
experiment unpublish we're just working
on it we gradually see we point out the
importance of instead of just rewiring
it when it comes back from each mission
or reprogramming it we want to be able
to inform it suggest it things to it
talk with it we want it we want it to be
in the space of reasons you have it
reasons yeah and so we want to install
language but we don't want to install
language the old-fashioned girl
fashioned AI way by you know designing
it and simply putting it in we want it
to learn in negotiation with us we want
it to be able to have its own way of
making points and as we think about the
task of helping a drone create a
language that it can use to communicate
with us in and we'd like it to be as
hosts I think we can get it and to teach
the drone English but we want to teach
that we want to drawn to learn English
not just be wired up for English at
birth this will give us models of
answers to all the hard questions
and might not be the correct answer for
our Braves they might not be but at
least but at least exactly and I think
that's the way a eye has always been it
gives you an existence proof yeah this
may not be the way we do it but it's a
way of doing this job and the idea that
it's magic or you know beyond human can
we know it's not beyond human can
because we found a way of doing it right
so it's very hard to even ask the hard
questions first of all we have no
personal private knowledge about how we
do it
suppose I ask you to imagine three cows
standing in the field and the one on the
left is brown and the other two are
mottled you can do it I do it yep Wow I
don't know yeah yeah you heard my
request and you were able to act on it
yeah now an interesting thing about just
a simple case like that another example
I want you to imagine putting a plastic
bucket over your head and climbing
hand-over-hand up a rope okay okay now I
deliberately chose items that would not
be alien to say a chimpanzee in the zoo
can the chimpanzee stimulate its own
brain can it could it we can't ask it
yeah can it ask itself can it does it
have the the layer of control
over its own cognitive processes so that
as it sat there not otherwise occupied
it could manipulate those familiar items
of its experience good question I don't
know the answer but I suspect the answer
is no and I suspect the answer is no
because you you can't do that
wordlessly until you can do it
interactively with language without
language I don't think you have the the
systems and your cognitive system for
self stimulation for self probing that
we have we are in we are virtuoso self
probers of our own brain it's
interesting I want to pause just to say
you've been going on for a little over
an hour now
I'm very happy to keep going I have a
lot to ask about but I don't want to
impose on you too much all right having
a great time good excellent it's very
interesting you say exactly that because
I once asked Steven Pinker
what is the role that language plays in
consciousness and he says none
whatsoever he said it's a completely
different thing yeah yes I know I know
Steve's few well and I think Steve was
tremendously smart much smarter than
some of his critics take him to be but I
think he's wrong about this got it okay
I didn't know what like all the experts
had it no no no I know I'm I'm pretty
much out on a limb here in claiming it
as I did in consciousness explained that
the human language doesn't just let us
talk about what we're conscious of human
language allows us to be conscious of
things that we otherwise wouldn't be
conscious
of things that bears and dogs and fish
and birds are not conscious of the way
we are right and I think once you
appreciate or if you appreciate if you
believe that recursion and self
representation things like that are
crucial then obviously language is a
hugely useful tool indeed I I think that
language is here this is a strange
inversion of say Tom sees you Chomsky
has the I think bizarre view that
recursion is a sort of Shazam gift of
natural selection this giant leap that
once you have recursion and everything
else falls into place and what it is the
the basis for for for language and
there's a sense in which I think he's
almost right but I think it's the other
way around
I think it's language that mean doesn't
make any heavy use of recursion in its
controls
gradually creates in us the capacity to
create recursive levels in our own
brains and it goes back to the thing I
was giving you some examples of a few
minutes ago like I can ask you okay now
I want you to imagine a blue triangle
and you can do that and not perfectly
but Daniel door has a book called the
instruction of imagination which is a
wonderfully um chomskyan look at
language and I think he's got a lot of
this right what
language permits is the development of a
sort of a place to stand you know our
Khomeini's and is give me a face to
stand and I'll move the world with a
lever language gives us places to stand
in our own cognition which permit us
then to self stimulate to probe to
explore our own brains and that's what
creates recursion and that's what
creates the creatures of recursion which
have things like qualia right it creates
a whole menagerie of properties that are
not real properties they are properties
that are the effects well no I it's hard
to say this they are subjective in the
sense that the appreciation of the
property is what brings it into
existence okay now I think I probably
agree with you too much about all these
issues but let me for purposes of
podcast conversation try to channel the
skeptics you know they place a huge
amount of emphasis on the distinction
between a sort of an external
third-person view in the internal first
perspective Chalmers go so far as to
imagine the possibility of a P zombie
that could act exactly like you do but
have no inner conscious experience it
always seems like a bit of a
conversation stopper to me that idea
that you need to speak the language of
first-person subjective experience even
to have this conversation because we're
all different I mean it you know it yeah
this is on the one hand I think the idea
of a philosophical zombie
is just an embarrassment somebody one
philosopher once said to me Dan if I
understand you right if I want to talk
about philosophical zombies I should
probably put a paper bag over my head I
said you know well I do think that
they're possible is that decibel I think
I think that I think that there's a way
of I think really showing that this is
whatever it was trying to do it doesn't
do a real job and it creates just
distracting monsters that should be
ignored
but then let's look at the job it was
trying to do and you had a pretty good
version of it just now when you said it
looks as if we need we can't just stay
with the third person point of view and
we need the first person point of view
so let's let's agree that what's really
amazing is that you have your point of
view and I have my point of view and we
know that and we can spend all day
comparing our points of view and that's
a phenomena that we want to explain
mm-hmm notice by the way let's imagine
some Martian scientists or you know
alien utterly alien intelligences I
think a lot of good science though and
they come to our planet and let's
suppose that they if we can imagine this
and maybe we can't but let's start with
the idea we can imagine they have no
idea of consciousness or quality at all
Martian zombies Martian zombies they're
Martian zombies but there not just
Martian by being a Martian zone
philosophical zombies it our Earthlings
know all about consciousness because
their because they have to to get by on
the world so well but these are these
are aliens and they come in they they
study us are they going to discover the
first-person point of view of course
they are
how by reading our novels by hearing how
we talk to each other our we have filled
the world with public third-person
accessible representations of our own
first-person subjectivity stream of
consciousness novels and this is all
available this is data hard data to the
Marcin zombies they can go and come
through our libraries and watch our
television shows and just overhear
conversations and they'll have a very
bill they'll soon learn if they learn
you know the rules of baseball and how
the stock market works they're also
going to learn that we all have a
first-person point of view
I did try unsuccessfully to convince
Chalmers that the philosophical zombie
argument was a great argument for
physicalism because if you really
believe that the zombie would act
exactly as the same collection of atoms
that had consciousness would you could
ask it what it was experiencing and it
would say oh I'm experiencing pain or
Brad or whenever but by hypothesis it's
not so it's lying and therefore you
don't know if you're experiencing those
things either because that's exactly
what you would do but he he didn't buy
that well I don't know what I've tried
the same argument on I mean I think in
the end for David and for say Galen
Strawson
another philosopher they're just so sure
that their intuition about their
first-person point of view is right that
they can't they can't even
hypothetically or for the sake of
argument they can't abandon that
intuition and you know I I appreciate
that inability or it's more of a
reluctance than an inability I feel the
same way when physicists start asking me
to set aside some of my intuitions yeah
about space and time it's over and I say
here yeah but something in me does I
don't know if if I try to abandon that
intuition I don't know what to trust
yeah well it calls up the reliability
the usefulness of introspection
generally right I mean introspection is
where we get a lot of these ideas of our
experiences should we be generally
skeptical of introspection we learn
something from it
we learn something from it but yes we
should be we should be skeptical first
of all let's start small and build up I
love to point out to my students and
others all the ways in which their
consciousness isn't the way they think
it is for instance it seems that our
color vision goes right way out to the
to the edge of our vision it doesn't it
seems that we have high resolution
vision out to the side we don't I love
to point out that the lots of things
that are surprising I can demonstrate to
them whoo-hoo well you didn't did so
forget about the so-called
incorrigibility of first-person
acquaintance it's that's just that's
just a mistake that doesn't mean that
we're not reliable informants to
ourselves and others about many features
but forget about
this Cartesian idea that on the inside
we are the masters of what's going so
you're saying that even when we
experience the outside world there's a
lot of stitching and jiggery-pokery that
comes together to give us this image we
have so why shouldn't the same thing be
true about our introspection well no I
think that yes I think we have very
clear cases where people miss introspect
if you like and and that raises the
possibility which I think every theorist
is sort of honorbound to take seriously
that their deepest intuitions their most
cherished intuitions about what their
first-person experiences might be
mistaken
wellnow humanely well I can see where
dennis is going here he's going to the
idea that we're all some beasts and but
that we have these strong intuitions
that we're not and in a sense I think
that's right
that in a sense in a sense that is when
we have a proper theory of consciousness
we look around inside we're not gonna
find any selves in there we're not gonna
find any witnesses in there so as far as
we can tell when we have that theory it
will be a theory which does not
distinguish zombies from conscious
beings now is that a feeling or that's
why it should be I think that's the way
it should be so in a sense the
distinction between a zombie a
philosophical zombie and a conscious
being no abandon that but then but then
we have plenty of room to distinguish
people's being conscious of this or that
and being unconscious of this
being not just you know in a coma but
yeah not cognizant to various things
that are going on around them things
happening beneath their notice things
that are subliminal things that are
unconsciously being that we can have
that wealth of cognitive science and
psychology which has been building up
for more than a hundred years is
available and that's all untouched by
this the one thing you have to give up
is this idea that you know that you're
not a philosophical zombie no that's
that's just an artifact of bad
theorizing so just to be super clear to
get the lingo right you are not claiming
that consciousness is an illusion it's
real in the same sense that the patterns
that we talked about are real I mean our
these concepts of experiences play a
useful role in how we explain well what
we go through well I'm glad you asked
that
yeah or or because because let's get it
right because I like the term illusion
okay and I think it's a generational
thing I think that the younger
generation has no trouble with illusion
as a positive term as in the user
illusion consciousness is a user
illusion in fact the manifest image is a
user illusion it's nature's way of
simplifying the world force in the same
way that software engineers have
brilliantly created these metaphorical
icons and sound effects and think of how
badly you would misunderstand the
computer if you tried to figure out how
computers work by simply extrapolating
from the user illusion yeah take
literally the files on your desktop
that's right the the the user illusion
is a brilliantly designed the user
illusion of a laptop or a smartphone it
is brilliantly designed to exploit your
perceptual and locomotory and hand
dexterity powers and and your audition
to use hearing to permit you to perform
things you want to do ignorant of the
details of how it's going on same thing
is true in your brain the one difference
is that there's no screen because
there's no eyeball in there so if you
want to know who is the who is the
victim of the you illusion know who's
the beneficiary as a user illusion but
now I'm a little confused because we
agreed that elements of manifest image
or an often oftentimes real well okay
so consciousness is both real and
evolution yeah yeah yeah and and that's
Frick is a better word than illusion
maybe trick is better word than illusion
well yeah for years I've been saying
consciousness is a bag of tricks it's a
whole lot of different tricks it's not
one big galumphing metaphysical trick
it's a whole lot of engineering tricks
and those engineering tricks create an
agent that has instant reliable
dexterous fluent use of a huge array of
representations the agent one doesn't
need to know how those representations
are created or in this case even where
they are or whether they have the
properties they seem to have
here's a way of thinking about it think
of stage magic often thing I like to use
examples from stage magic there's a sort
of honor code among magicians you're
supposed to you're supposed to show
something you show not tell you haven't
done a trick if you simply bribed the or
we can we can we can test our intuitions
here what would you think of a magician
that used mass hypnosis and simply could
hypnotize the whole audience and then
you know have flaming elephants dancing
on their toes and and no display at all
nothing on the stage the magician is all
along but everybody is just going oh and
I would say well that's uh sort of the
sheet yeah that doesn't really count
well why not so instead of hypnosis
let's do it scientifically but let's
let's say that you've got a magician who
says I now ask people to wear special
headset to my magic shows and this is a
headset which simply beams I keep it
dead simple just beams directly to
occipital cortex v1 the the sort of
first major way station for for all
visual information and it can simply
create hallucinations there this is him
bypassing the eyeballs photons eyeballs
no longer part but everything else you
know from the SA from could be from the
optic nerve maybe what he's doing is he
simply captured the optic nerve
this device everything from the optic
nerve in is as it would be if there was
a flaming elephant standing on this
trunk would that be magic but but at
least we now have people that were darn
tootin sure that they had seen an
elephant standing on its trunk on the
stage question would they have koala no
wait we've thrown away the screen you
know yeah there's no more room they
think they have qualia they think
they've seen the elephant but they
haven't seen they had they think they've
had the experience of seeing Bo that's
right well they have had the experience
of seeing an elephant it's a bogus
experience yeah because there was no
elephant out there but I mean if we take
the whole phenomenon from from the light
hitting whatever's on the stage up
through the eyes and through to final to
the conviction centre to what people
will swear on a Bible they saw at every
point we could in principle intervene
and lay out the the food for the
consumers at the next layer level and it
might be very very light and if it was
very very late you might get some very
anomalous things like this is weird I
could for a moment there I could have
sworn that there was an elephant on this
stage I mean it just sort of hit me but
um no details or anything I mean we do
have experiences like that short oh yeah
so there's a sense in which
consciousness is real is also a sense in
which
it's evolution ya know and and in
particular there's the theorist solution
okay what's that the theorist solution
is what the theorist may have in the dog
doesn't the dog doesn't think it has
qualia right the theorist does that's
just yeah that's just false that's just
that's a that's an artifact bad theory
so would we take the same angle on
freewill that there's an aspect of it
that's real aspect of which is an
illusion yes that's the philosophers
favorite answer yes the traditional idea
freewill where somehow our bodies or our
brains are shielded from causation
that's crap
yeah that's it's just gotta be false
we're not lower than torso
we're not lost and we're not there's no
miracles happening like that so if
that's what you think freewill has to be
if you think freewill is incompatible
with say determinism then there's no
free will
yeah then freewill isn't real it's an
illusion but but but I would prefer to
say free wills perfectly real as justice
and what you think it is yeah which you
did predict ahead of time that you were
gonna say so good so but it is so in the
sense in which it's real has something
to do with the fact that it plays this
explanatory role in the manifestation
not just an explanatory role it plays a
huge role in people's lives yeah as I
was saying before
since our society has the concept of
free will I signed the mortgage papers
for this house I was asked if I was
giving my signing this of my own free
will
[Laughter]
the nobody agent have any other notaries
talking to notary was reading this awful
piece of paper and I was only too happy
to answer but some people don't have
free will some people are incapacity yet
some people aren't in control so there's
a very real difference and it makes a
huge difference in life but I like to
put it this way
consider back to our drone suppose we
throw away the controller and just let
it be its own self controlled autonomous
thing pretty dangerous yeah well you
think that stagers think how dangerous
we are empirically we're pretty darn
dangerous yes empirically we have we
have millions of degrees of freedom and
we're not in anybody's control barrel or
we can try to control pew parents I like
the idea that parents eventually have to
launch their children and once they've
launched them they're no longer guided
missiles they're there now
autonomous yeah and how do we dare let
people do this we dare let people do
this because we trust the people will
have done their best to turn their
offspring into self controlled
responsible agents and that's what free
will is and there's no metaphysical
bright line but there are lots of legal
bright lines and they are negotiable and
invasive and there's a sort of arms race
going on where as we discover one
loophole or another we either exempt or
not various people from responsibility
or
responsibilities well it's the it's
legal responsible moral questions that
that make this very vivid and absolutely
and I know that you said things I want
to take this opportunity to clarify as
much as we can you you've sort of hinted
at the idea that even though we
sophisticated scientists and
philosophers know that there are laws of
physics and we all obey them we should
let the people have their free will in
some sense because it makes them act
more morally that may or may not be true
for me personally that fact has nothing
to do with why I think that it's
sensible to talk about freewill
by my reason for talking about freewill
is just the answer you just gave which
is that it does play this role in
helping you explain Meadows on well I
think I don't think that the idea that
we have freewill is a sort of holy myth
that we should preserve but you know for
the good of hoi polloi no no we all need
it I think it's extremely paternalistic
patronizing to say well I don't need you
losing a free will but every day folks
they need it no I think that's first of
all I think that's just obnoxious right
we all go through life gauging our
opportunities making choices taking them
as seriously as we do which is sometimes
not seriously enough and some trying to
persuade and sometimes it's too serious
I'm trying to persuade others it's no
secret that this pattern of activity
including mental activity including
Hamlet like thinking and mulling and
musing and worrying it's no secret why
it exists it's it's what makes
civilization possible and I for one
would rather live in a civilized world
but so that's a very crucial distinction
has the danger of slipping by there it's
not that we need to tell people they
have free will to make them civilized is
that we have to appreciate that we have
free will so that we create civilization
yes absolutely right yes that's very
good but that does mean that the free
will skeptics including some they're
really they're really engaging in a sort
of an anti-social behavior it's a sort
of it's a sort of cognitive and ilysm I
try to shock them all that I have a
little thought experiment about that
it's possible if you have a obsessive
compulsive disorder to have a little
device installed in your in your brain
that that will help control it and
that's the fact so for now we're gonna
have little science fiction so this chap
has obsessive-compulsive disorder and he
goes to his local neurosurgeon and asks
for the installation and she installs it
and then after he wakes up after the
operation she says now you're free to go
oh and by the way
yeah we're in radio control here we
monitor you 24/7 and if you ever are
about to commit some terrible act we
intervene of course have a nice life I
think that's a black viewer episode yeah
you have watched like you know I know I
think that if you if you have any
inclination whatsoever that especially
big the first few seasons of black
mirror are made for you
you should watch all of them okay
they're all thought experiments about
how technology is are breaking into our
lives okay so I wonder if like Mary
as the sequel that I have so this fellow
goes off and reassured that he set the
safety in that he becomes you know a
little bit slovenly in his
decision-making and he makes some bad
decisions pretty soon he ends up in
court and the judge confronts him and
asks him well no I don't have any free
will you know I'm in control just obey
the laws of physics and and the
neurosurgeons you know they're there I'm
their puppet and the judge calls and
neurosurgeon says did you did you tell
this man that when you put this device
in henceforth it he would be a sort of
electronically controlled puppet and she
said yeah he says it's not true he says
no we're just messing with his brain now
she did something evil right well if she
in her white coat her scientists white
coat is doing something evil for that
guy what about you folks out there in
science land who are going around
telling everybody that free will is an
illusion that they don't that they're
all really just puppets why isn't that
the same sort of antisocial behavior
that this neurosurgeon this imaginary
neurosurgeon is engaged in I like that
okay very good I will remember that not
have the black mirror episode ended but
still a good one good I think to wrap up
let's deviate a little bit from you've
had a long career with many greatest
hits I think we fit we've hit some of
them here but what are the there's a
worldview that you're sketching out that
is very coherent and fits together in in
various ways laws of physics Darwinian
evolution intentional stances real
patterns
what are the implications of that as
we've been we've begun to touch on this
but for morality for ethics for how we
should live our lives right is there a
meta ethical conclusion that comes from
this or even ethical conclusions well
yes I think there is and part of it is
yet another aspect to my work we haven't
mentioned is it means we don't need
religion religion was maybe a good
scaffold on which to build civilization
maybe it the myths of religion kept
people in line and and cooperating
because they were worried about big
Rolla wat watching them and maybe I'm
quite content with hypotheses not
provable but they might be true that say
that that civilization depended on
religion I don't think it does that
anymore I think we we can grow up and
simply abandon the myths but when we do
that we want to be sure that we don't
destroy or discard some of the valuable
things that came along with that the one
that that most concerns me
is one that you can get at with the line
of Robert Frost's home is where when you
have to go there they have to take you
in now in that sense there's a lot of
people that are homeless and don't trust
the state to take care of them one of
the things that religions have done over
the decades over the millennia is taken
in and provided a sense of meaning and
love for people who otherwise would not
have that and those of us who were
fortunate enough to
live exciting lives should recognize
that this is a social service to call it
that is to underplay its significance by
orders of magnitude this is a life
healing life protecting life improving
feature of the world that we don't want
to throw away the question is how do you
save it without also saving the sort of
brute irrationality or a rationality the
valorisation of unreason and
superstition I think it's possible to
domesticate religions a little further
they've been domesticated a lot but I
think we can go a little farther and
keep ceremony keep community keep music
and art and celebration intact and leave
out the myths but that's a tall order
but I see progress all around and I do
share the concern that a lot of people
have that that while the the fastest
growing group in the world is the nuns
the Nano and yes those that have no
religion at all if they have no
community if they have no allegiance if
they have no if there's nothing that
they think of that's bigger than a more
important than they are to guide their
lives then we're in trouble it just
shouldn't be listened yeah
so I think morality is itself a is a
human it's a social construct and not
moral realist yeah and again it's it's
really just isn't what you think it is
it's not given by God it isn't deducible
from the set of axioms it's a in a
certain sense political and rational
prehab creation of ideally an informed
community of people so I mean it we
exercise our free will to create yeah we
we can imagine as a sort of grounding
myth the philosophers like to do this
sort of thing
you all come everybody come you're all
welcome
you got to obey some rules some rules of
discourse and whatever your current
beliefs are about what's right and
what's wrong
share them with us if there's something
that your group thinks is really really
wrong and the rest of us haven't seen
that yeah that might be eating meat or
it might be well any of the things that
religions have to have boos about don't
just play the faith chart and say well
I'm a nexus to Nexus I think this is a
sin no your task is to convince the rest
of us that you're right give us reasons
give us reasons if you can persuade us
that there's a case to be made we'll
listen
but if you play the faith card if you
say
this is beyond reason this is this is
simply Who I am I can do no other
basically what you're doing when you say
that is you're saying I'm disqualified
from this this discussion I'm disabled
my my irrationality prevents me from
playing the role that's available to me
here and I think if we imagine morality
as whatever emerges from that in the
ideal circumstance that's the kind of
human construction it is well I think
I've done a terrible job at playing the
devil's advocate here cuz I agree with
you too much but Dan Dennett thanks very
much for being on the podcast was very
education well thank you Shawn you asked
all the right questions
[Music]
you
[Music]